This is a download from BBC Learning English to find out more, visit our website.
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English, I'm Neil.
And I'm Rob. Do you enjoy your own company, Rob? Do you like being alone or do you prefer spending
time with friends? Well, recently I haven't seen my friends much because of coronavirus.
In fact, I've hardly seen anyone this past year.
It sounds like Rob has become a bit of a hermit, someone who lives alone and apart from society.
Yes, I've been forced to spend time alone, but it wouldn't be my choice. I'd much rather be socialising
and visiting friends. If Rob, the idea of being alone does not appeal to you,
it might be hard to understand why anyone would choose to be a hermit, but some people do,
and in this programme we'll be hearing some of the reasons why.
Throughout history and across all cultures, there have been people who choose to leave behind
the life and people they know to live in isolation and silence. People like Christopher Wright,
an American man who lived in complete isolation in the forests of Maine for nearly 30 years.
When Hikeers discovered his tent, all they found was an alarm clock. So my quiz question is this,
why did Christopher Wright, the hermit of the main words, need an alarm clock?
Was it A, to remind him when to hide his tent? B, to frighten away wild animals?
Or C, to wake him up at the coldest part of the night so he didn't freeze to death?
Well, if he wanted to be alone so much, I guess he needed to be invisible. So I'll say A,
to remind him to hide his tent.
Okay, Rob will find out the answer later. Christopher Wright may be an extreme example of someone
seeking solitude, but there are many other motivations for becoming a hermit.
Some people are looking for peace and silence, and for others it's about being closer to God,
focusing on what's inside and finding a sense of joy.
Meng Hu is a former librarian who now runs a website all about hermit. He says that in ancient times,
many Chinese hermit seeking solitude were followers of the philosopher Confucius.
Here's Meng Hu talking about Confucius to BBC World Service program, the wife actor.
His dictum was something like when the emperor is good serve, when the emperor is evil,
recluse. And so over 1000 years at least, there were a lot of recluse. There were a lot of educated men
who simply couldn't tolerate any more evil. They simply dropped out and they would migrate to small
villages to farms. Meng Hu mentions Confucius' dictum. A dictum is a short statement or saying which
expresses some wise advice or a general truth about life. Confucius' dictum advised that when the
emperor was evil, people should become recluse. People like hermit who live alone and avoid contact
with others. In the interview, Meng Hu uses recluse as a verb to recluse, that this is very uncommon,
a more modern way of saying this is to drop out, to reject the normal way society works and live
outside the system. A bit like the hippies in the 1960s you mean. Right, although most hippies weren't
looking for isolation, they did have something in common with hermit, the desire to challenge
society's rules and conventions. Someone who combines the hippie and the hermit is Catholic writer
Sarah Mateland. Part of a long tradition of Christian hermit's, Sarah spent 40 days and nights alone
on the Isle of Sky seeking God in the silence of the remote Scottish island. For her, the magic of
silence is something to be embraced and taught to children. Here she explains more to BBC World
Services, the wife actor. Most people first encounter silence in bereavement, in relationship
breakdown and in death. And that seems to me about the worst place to start. But people say, well,
what should we do? I mean, never ever use go to your room on your own as a punishment. You use it
as a reward. Darling, you've been so good all day, you've been so helpful. Why don't you go to your
room for half an hour now and be on your own? Treat the reward! Sarah says that most people experience
silence after a bereavement, the death of a relative or close friend. She also thinks parents
should never tell their children, go to your room as a punishment. Instead being alone should be a
treat, a reward or gift of something special and enjoyable. That way, children learn that being
alone can actually be enjoyable. I'm still wondering about that American Christopher Wright. I suppose
living alone in the woods was a treat for him. I suppose so, but why did he need an alarm clock?
Ah yes, your quiz question, Neil. I thought maybe it was to remind him to hide his tent. Was I right?
Well, incredibly robbed, the answer was c'd wake him up at the coldest part of the night so he
didn't freeze to death. That's someone who really wants to be left alone. A hermit's, in other words,
or a recluse, two ways of describing people who live alone and avoid others.
Okay, let's recap the rest of the vocabulary starting with dictum, a short saying often giving
wise advice or expressing a general truth about life. People who drop out reject the normal
rules of society and live outside the system. Many people experience solitude after a bereavement,
the death of a close friend or relative. And finally, a treat is a reward or gift of something
special and enjoyable. That's all for now, but whether you're listening alone or with others,
we hope you'll join us again soon here at six minute English. Don't forget to you'll find us
on our website or you can download our free app so you won't miss any of our programs and we're
on all the main social media sites. Bye bye. Bye for now.